not having a good pitch video to me I
feel like is the ones I've seen I'm like
and I would never donate to that because
the video wasn't good whether it was a
production value or just the pitch
wasn't good I just didn't feel like it
was a compelling enough story or you
know that kind of stuff if you have a
really fantastic crowdfunding video and
and it's you know pulling at people's
heart strings the only reason there's
they're not contributing well I'll say
this number one is maybe that's a
fantastic pitch video by someone
standards but not by the standards of
the audience that are actually there for
the movie so there's that piece but if
it really is like an exceptional
crowdfunding video I've never seen an
exceptional crowdfunding video no one
time I did actually one time on seating
spark probably still the best
crowdfunding video I've ever seen in my
life and the campaign went nowhere and
that's because they did zero outreach
and nobody saw it right so you can't
just make an excellent crowdfunding
video and put it on a website and hope
that somebody sees it you felt it right
well they have this great project that I
I backed and I tweeted about it and I
went back a couple days later and they
didn't have any more backers and went
back a couple weeks later and they
didn't have any more backers I was like
that means to me that they didn't even
put in the effort to con their friends
into back in their project which means
that maybe they should look into how
crowdfunding works some more and try
again I think there's projects that I
thought were going to get funded because
they're so inspiring and they're so
magical on you know this photographer
person wanted to put together this
amazing travel blog about different
photography things and it was just like
really interesting to me I put in my ten
dollars but you know she needed like 200
people to do that and it didn't quite
catch on fire and you wonder like well
how do these out of these catch on fire
what is what leads something to be okay
we made a hundred percent of our of our
goal sometimes you're just shocked and
you're like what happened mostly it's
just trying to get the word out and
trying to get people to repost it
retweet
and that sort of thing would because
that's really eyeballs getting eyeballs
on the project on the on the video
because if they liked the video well
definitely the the quality of the video
I mean every everyone says that you know
is it framed correctly like little like
filmmaking 101 that a lot of people you
know here they're asking for money to
make a movie but their Kickstarter video
like doesn't have proper framing the
framing is weird or you know they don't
have a good sound or good audio or the
edits aren't smooth or they only have
one angle they don't decide to like
cover it from multiple angles stuff like
that I would and sort of a vision like I
can get a sense of what they're trying
to do and why they build up compelling
reason as to why I should give you know
why I should be be part of it and I
think a lot of has to do with sort of a
vision the style of the video I think
that's a big part of it you know does it
feel like its own little thing and its
own is it have a beginning a middle and
add in you know is it you know do they
have a visual sense of being telling a
story because the Kickstarter video is a
story you know you're you know you're
telling store in three minutes as to who
you are what you need you what you've
done if they can do that then in a lot
of icy a lot of kickstart videos and
aren't stories that aren't they don't
they don't have an arc and that's what I
try to do in my campaign a little bit
and I'm realizing I you know could have
done things better but so in a nutshell
then good crowdfunders script their
crowdfunding videos oh I did I had a
whole I script in mind weeks in advance
man I mean I was like I was walking in
like I was an actor almost like God you
know I mean yeah absolutely i wasn't
gonna wing it and i had to actually had
a script script girl on the other side
who was helping me with you know hey you
missed this point or you missed this and
i wasn't i didn't trust myself as far as
making sure because you know you have
like three pages of tax to get through a
dialogue put a couple months in on the
video
and part of it one thing I recognized
with kick started it was very very clear
is that you have to have the personal
touch it's the person the individual
saying hi this is who I am I really
would like your help it's usually one
person whether it's double fine or
Amanda Palmer it's usually the one on
one unfortunately I was a commentator on
morning edition for three years long ago
and I've done a lot of media interviews
and so I'm very comfortable with that
and I think that helped but also in my
campaign it was me as a person but it
was also this is the body of work I've
done and then the third part is this is
a team I've assembled and it's an
amazing team and then it was the special
effects shots that we were generating
fresh saying this is what what we're
doing is going to look like so it wasn't
just you can look at our work from the
past but there's no telling what we're
going to do now here's something very
concrete let me generated new specific
to this project and that was very
important because otherwise people are
going to be dubious but if you say okay
look look at this if you like this if
you like these effects shots if you like
these actors who are going to be casting
then you've got a pretty good idea about
what we're up to number one the most
important thing is to start from a place
of passion I think I could probably I
would not have had a successful
Kickstarter campaign we would've had a
successful Kickstarter campaign if we
weren't truly one hundred percent
passionate about the film because your
passion I think will come through in any
type of motion you do video to me seems
like the biggest no-brainer of all time
for filmmakers but a lot you know a lot
of filmmakers that for whatever reason
either their gun shy about getting a
camera or they don't want to come off as
you know arrogant or papas or you know
what all the all the typical you know
ways that people like to think of you
know crazy filmmakers the truth is if
you care enough about your project to
you no sweat blood and tears to get it
done you should care enough to tell
people why and I think that if you start
from a place of honesty and passion in
however you're communicating it all
you'll already be ahead of the pack I
think the mistake then Allah I see a lot
of indie film makers make when they
start making some sort of tape is that
they'll try to maybe like a
copy a different campaign that was
successful but that may be completely
inappropriate for what it is they're
doing it more often than not you watch a
filmmaker and you go who cares you know
I you know I I don't care i bet you a
lot of the filmmakers when they watch
that own tape they probably don't
probably doesn't move them but i think
if you again if you start from a place
of honesty and and you you create
something that's as real as the movie
you made in the first place something is
personal and cooling quirky and
interesting as your own work people are
going to respond and I mean listen I'm a
big sound but I when I watch our
Kickstarter video I still tear up and
you know yes part of it is cuz i have to
admit that i looked at goofy on camera
but part of it is because i really i
really do it the journey meant so much
to us that it was impossible not to be
passionate when we talked about it so i
think my first tip would be start from a
place of honesty a passion what's your
simmons yet i'm getting it in order no I
know what is I know what my second tip
is but good I thought you might want to
expand um expand on the passion no I
absolutely agree we we're working with
some filmmakers now who are doing a
documentary called journey through fire
and they actually came and one of the
video things that they're doing which I
thought was really nice is there talking
to different filmmakers and having them
almost pitch to film where you know to
me what is it that inspired to them
about the film or what is it that
inspires them about the project which I
think again to the passion that it's not
just a filmmakers passion but the show
that the film has inspired a passionate
response in others I think definitely
helps in terms of having you know
testimonials you know within the pitch
video which is not something we did but
I saw them doing it um just recently
you're working we did different kinds of
testimony right but you know for them it
really I mean they're still in
in the editing process they don't have
their film finished yet you know we saw
rough cuts and little bits and pieces
and you know found out about the stories
and all of that but um you know again
it's speaking to The Passion it's just
what's your passion if you know if I'm
an audience member and you know you're
the filmmaker of course you're
passionate about your project but to see
somebody else get passionate about your
project who's not necessarily connected
to it in any way that's intriguing and
then I go oh you know what what is in
your project that sparks their passions
and that may also dance part mine and I
think a 11 idea that you're hitting on
there that I do think is important if
you're lucky enough to have it is social
proof you know um basically proof that
there is a love of your project outside
your own blog because of course you love
her do you wouldn't know if you know
spent all your money and all your time
making it we were so lucky to that when
we played our initial festivals that we
were not only winning but we were
getting standing ovations and and we we
brought cameras with us to the
screenings in hopes of gathering some
type of audience reaction in far
exceeded our expectations but being able
to show people our film is receiving one
standing ovation after another and
people in the lobby are unable to
contain themselves and they're in there
they're crying and talking about the
film and this is what real people are
saying about the movie I think went a
lot of credibility and it also made
people feel good about supporting the
film whether it was donating or watching
or deciding to buy a ticket it's like
well there's other people in the world
are being moved by this movie that only
said not only says to me that it's good
it also says to me this is something I
want to be a part of you know am I
missing out by not seeing this film is
it we know what my life you know maybe
be touched like that person's life was
touched if I took the time to go see it
or not all movies are need to be
touching it could be a comedy you know
am I going to have that much fun at the
movies you know is is it worth me going
to escape for a few hours so I do think
that if you can hint that social proof
in any kind of pitch you do for anything
just proving that there's there's a more
universal uh you know attractiveness to
your project I do think that will help
um the next point that I think is really
important and I think this speaks to
again and it doesn't matter if you're
making a movie if you're selling widgets
you know if you're you're trying to get
booked to give speeches of whatever I
think you have to know your audience you
know it's really important to know that
audience and to speak to them um and and
I don't do that necessarily mean a lot
of people go oval who's your audience
and I know all about to start breaking
it down into demographics I don't think
that necessarily works as well for
independent filmmakers I mean yes it's
important to know in general you know
this movie is going to appeal to men
more than women or vice versa but a lot
of times indie filmmakers fall into this
weird in-between place because we're
making something that's different and it
doesn't necessarily fit one specific
mold so I think you want to figure out
how to appeal to certain pieces and
everybody I mean I think we all have you
know in the case of Dinah do Letterman I
think we all have an underdog spirit no
matter who you are in the matter if your
man or woman no matter what age you are
all of us at some point in our lives
have been the underdog or rooted for
another dog and that was something we
worked really hard to tap into when we
you know wonder reached out and I was
not only reflected in our video which
very clearly said no one wanted us to
make this movie which was true people
said it you know it was a horrible idea
to shoot the film people thought we were
crazy to invest our money in it I mean
we were underdogs Steve's story is a
major underdog story so by saying the
people you know look we're underdogs be
part of our underdog story I think that
helped them relate to the movie I think
if you can find something that's
universal in your film and B and think
of that as your demographic what's my
demographic its underdogs we all have a
little piece of the underdog in us so in
a way it makes it easier to focus your
message like like you're tapping into
that essence as opposed to I'm just
going for the you know 18 to 39 year old
male which probably if you're
independent filmmaker you probably don't
fit a category quite so sharply unless
you set out to make a commercial film
which is a whole different business plan
all together
so one we applaud what's that well I I
listen I I I think yes that's that's a
whole side I think unfortunately I think
a lot of independent filmmakers get
lumped into what you'd only make one
kind of movie which is not true an
independent filmmaker as a person that
goes and makes a movie with their own
money because no one else will pay for
it you know I think that if Sloane went
out and they did their independent
version of Armageddon god bless I'd
support him a hundred percent I do think
there's a bias against you know young
aspiring filmmakers who tend to make
stuff that appeals to the masses as
opposed to the niche audiences so for
the record I completely support anybody
and applaud anybody who has the gumption
to finish a movie and if your movie
happens to the Armageddon or horror
movie or a comedy and it doesn't fit
your typical you know festival festival
model it's I i don't think people should
care i think you should be applauded for
finishing your film in the first place
so that's a whole rant for another day
how important was it for you to make it
personal because i like how you talk
about in your kickstarter video Alton
Illinois and you talk about the
different I think was the world's
tallest man yeah nice Davis yeah exactly
so you personalize it you you let us get
to know who you are where you're from
right how important was that that was
extremely important because I go back to
Alton I had take a lot of pride in the
community but I think a big thing was
that I'm a big advocate of Midwest
filmmakers and Midwest artists and and
to say hey I'm from Alton you never
heard of Alton this is what Alton is
known for and I really want the
community of Alton to come out support
the Kickstarter campaign you know
there's 30,000 people of an Alton and
all the peripheral city's east alma
bethalto and Godfrey all these it's the
river bend community and I want to get
the Riverbend community behind in the
buck and I'm struggling to do that
because nobody not enough people know
about it so and I think a lot of it has
to do with the fact that crowdfunding
while it's popular to people like us who
are involved in social media you go to
the Middle America you say the word
Kickstarter you know they think you're
talking about a part on a motorcycle or
something they don't they don't they
don't
you know people that live in LA in New
York and even Chicago we're all isolated
and this all the social media you know
we you know really we're in a bubble
compared to middle America you know so i
think i'm trying to penetrate that sense
of what it means and they're just not
familiar enough so that's been my major
obstacle i think if i was from a bigger
city it would be different it's way too
long always that's the problem you know
people have such a short attention span
you gotta sell this thing in two minutes
you know I just can't do it I just can't
do it I mean this video is probably the
longest video out there on Kickstarter
but i don't care i just feel it just
conveys the journey and emotion and you
know and it's designed i hope in a way
where after two minutes people can get
it and if they don't know 10 what's the
whole thing they can just stop and still
you know get what the whole story is
about I don't know who wrote the
handbook and disseminated it behind my
back that says the first thing that
happens in a crowdfunding pitch video is
you should sit in front of the camera
and talk at people like we we are in a
visual medium and we're always told in
our scripts and in our films to show not
tell and then we do a crowdfunding pitch
video and all we do is tell so here's my
favorite crowdfunding pitch video
blooper right mmm hi my name is Emily
best I actually do it this way hi my
name is Emily best and if this were
really one I would have bad sound right
now so lousy sounds hi my name is Emily
best I'm the writer-director lead actor
and producer of danger in downtown LA
danger in downtown LA is a terrifying
thriller starring me a woman that's like
not totally typical and we have this
incredible script and this amazing cast
of people who you will meet and talk to
in a minute but in I really want you to
get a sense of like what the film is
going to feel like so here's our
cinematographer who's going to talk to
you about why this is going to be a good
film and then you're going to talk to
the cinematographer for a little bit and
then you'll talk to a couple of the
actors and then you'll come back
they'll be like so um you know we're
totally broke you know indie filmmaking
we don't have any money we really need
your money that's the most important
thing that we could ask of you so donate
now and thanks bye we're gonna make
really scary film for you um I've seen
that video we've also in this video and
they're like I know I think it's good
and look by what standard if your movie
is okay I have so many things to say
about it first if we if you put nothing
else on the internet put this on the
Internet do not ask for help with a
donation because by and large unless you
are backed by a 501c3 asking for a
donation is factually incorrect right
the tone of your campaign should be
asking someone to join what you are
offering with a contribution that means
you are making a contribution and they
are making a contribution and together
you're going to make something
magnificent okay that tone has to
permeate everything in your crowdfunding
campaign I am offering you such a
kickass opportunity to join this thing
that's going to be so exciting strap on
your seatbelts this rocket is taking off
let's do this together like you be the
fuel I'll be the rocket and you be the
fuel right that's kind of what we're
talking about so the first thing is if
you are going to make a film let's say
called danger in downtown LA I don't
know if that film exists but I'm making
one up for these purposes for no money
at all you could take this lovely canon
5d or even your iPhone and make it feel
found-footage e and now this
neighborhood gets very dark at night and
the lighting is very weird and now I'm
over the shoulder of a woman I can tell
because her breathing is deep and we're
walking down in it's a alleyway and it's
kind of unsteady and you hear something
and it seems like maybe somebody's just
run behind you you turn around and
there's nothing there and then you turn
back and the the music kind of comes in
you can find tons of free creepy music
out there if you have a friend with a
keyboard they can create something for
you and then all of a sudden there's a
and a smash and the woman and the camera
are down on the ground and the breathing
is having you don't know what happens in
do it hi my name is Emily best that was
the first little snippet of danger in
downtown LA we have an incredible cast
and crew lined up I want to show you
first what our cinematographer is
capable of and then you spend you know
12 or 15 seconds with all of the cool
other stuff that your cinematographer
has done and maybe a cut of a few things
that your actors have been in if you
don't have time to shoot something sort
of native there is the the whole point
is that if you're going to make a small
movie a pitch video 90 seconds usually
about why somebody should get involved
with this much longer movie you're
proposing to make your small movie has
to be good and in the tone and
demonstrate that you are capable of
making the thing that you are promising
on long run and if you can't make a
90-second video basically for free that
gets people super excited maybe you
shouldn't be making the longer movie
sorry